[Music]
in this video we will study about the
beta oxidation of fatty acids beta
oxidation is a catabolic pathways of
fats in which free fatty acids are
converted to acetyl-coa since this
process involves oxygen in one form or
another it is known as oxidation but why
is this process called beta oxidation a
farts are stored in the human body in
various forms and one of the major
storage form are the triglycerides
triglycerides compose of a single
molecule of glycerol which is attached
to 3 molecules of fatty acid it is
important to understand the structure of
a fatty acid here are two images that
depict the chemical structure of fatty
acid it consists of a long chain of
carbon and hydrogen atoms
which is denoted as our this side chain
is attached to the functional group the
carboxyl group which is C double o H now
we know that the our side chain consists
of single chain of carbon and hydrogen
atoms let's expand this chain a bit the
carbon atom that is directly attached to
the functional group is known as the
alpha carbon and the carbon atom next to
the alpha carbon is the beta carbon in
beta oxidation of fatty acids the our
chain is broken down between alpha and
beta carbons and hence the name B to
oxidation
let's have an overview about the process
of beta oxidation the human body
contains adipose tissue which consists
of triglycerides the triglycerides
contain fatty acids and glycerol
molecules the fatty acids are
distributed all over the human body and
from there they enter into the blood to
the blood they're distributed to
virtually all the cells of the body that
can metabolize fatty acids the fatty
acids then move inside the cytoplasm of
the target cells in the next phase the
fatty acids enter into the matrix of the
mitochondria after crossing the inner
and outer mitochondrial membranes in the
final phase the fatty acids are
metabolized oxidatively inside the
mitochondrial matrix so the whole
process of beat oxidation can be divided
into three phases a transport of fatty
acids from the adipose tissue to the
target cells we entry of the fatty acids
into the cytoplasm and then into the
mitochondria of t-cells and see
oxidative catabolism inside the
mitochondrial matrix so let's first talk
about the transport of free fatty acids
from adipose tissue to the target cells
like we just discussed the human body
contains fats which have adipose cells
in them the fats are located in main
areas like abdomen thighs and arms the
adipose cells contains triglycerides
which have glycerol in combination with
three free fatty acids the combination
of glycerol with free fatty acids is
important because glycerol has a large
molecular mass which prevents the escape
of free fatty acids from adipose cells
here the enzyme lipase comes into play
which breaks the bond between glycerol
and free fatty acids once his bond is
broken the free fatty acids can enter
into the bloodstream and virtually reach
any cell of the body that is able to
metabolize free fatty acids
now there are two tissues in the body
that cannot metabolize free fatty acids
which are the RBC's and the nervous
tissue both of these tissues have one
thing in common that they lack
mitochondria and mitochondria are
essential for fatty acid metabolism
so here is a target cell that is able to
metabolize free fatty acids with the
help of mitochondria the free fatty acid
first enters into the cytoplasm of the
cell through a special protein called
fatty acid transporter the free fatty
acids have a net negative charge and
they cannot cross the membranes of the
cells as such and they require special
transporters to cross the membranes in
the next step the free fatty acid must
enter into the matrix of the
mitochondria after crossing its outer
and inner mitochondrial membrane the
matrix of the mitochondria is important
because it contains all the enzymes that
are required for the beat oxidation of
fatty acids as well as the enzymes for
Krebs cycle and electron transport chain
before the free fatty acid can be
transported into the mitochondrial
matrix it must be activated so let's
talk about the next part that is the
activation and transport of free fatty
acid inside the target cell mitochondria
so first talking about the fatty acid
activation
a free fatty acid must be converted into
its active form that is the SI l Kawai
SI l co is the only form that can be
metabolized inside the mitochondrial
matrix
this reaction is catalyzed by the enzyme
si el Kawai synthetase and in this
reaction a molecule of ATP is converted
into mono phosphate and a molecule of
pyrophosphate is released coenzyme a is
also essential for this reaction this
reaction takes place at many sites in
the cell including the outer
mitochondrial membrane the endoplasmic
reticulum and the peroxisomes the fatty
acid activation is very very essential
because without the activation the fatty
acids cannot be utilized as such in the
mitochondria
now once activated the free fatty acids
are then transported into the
mitochondria let's understand this
transport in a bit detail so on one side
we have the cytoplasm of the cell we
have the outer mitochondrial membrane
and the inner mitochondrial membrane the
space between them is known as inter
membrane space and on one side we have
the matrix of the mitochondria the outer
mitochondrial membrane contains these
small pore like structures called porins
which make the outer mitochondrial
membrane very permeable to many
substances including si el Cucuy so si
el Co a can freely transport inside the
inter membrane space after crossing the
outer mitochondrial membrane but after
that the inner mitochondrial membrane is
not permeable so we require a special
mechanism to transport the assignee
couette through the inner mitochondrial
membrane into the matrix this mechanism
is called the carnitine shuttle now the
carnitine shuttle contains many enzymes
and one of them is the carnitine
palmitoyl transferase one located in the
outer mitochondrial membrane the main
job of the enzyme carnitine palmitoyl
transferase one is that it attaches a
molecule of carnitine to as'll cuy in
this reaction the coenzyme a of si L Co
a is released back into the cytoplasm
and a molecule of s I'll contain is
generated inside the inter membrane
space
in the next step the enzyme carnitine
acyl carnitine translocase which is
located on the inner mitochondrial
membrane transports this acyl carnitine
into the matrix of the mitochondria but
like we just discussed si el coche is
the only form of the fatty acid that can
be metabolized inside the mitochondrial
matrix so it must be regenerated
this job is done by the enzyme carnitine
palmitoyl transferase 2
this enzyme attaches coenzyme a again to
the asylum molecule and regenerates the
carnitine back the carnitine that is
regenerated back is transported again
into the intermembrane space that can be
utilized by the carnitine palmitoyl
transferase one you can see in this
illustration that the enzyme carnitine
as'll carnitine translocase transports
one molecule of carnitine into the
intermembrane space and in exchange of
that it transports one molecule of acyl
carnitine into the matrix of the
mitochondria so this is how the free
fatty acid is transported into the
mitochondrial matrix up till now we have
studied the transport of free fatty
acids from adipose tissue to the target
cells we have also studied about the
entry of free fatty acids into a
cytoplasm and mitochondria in the next
part of the video we will discuss in
detail about the oxidative catabolism
that happens inside the mitochondrial
matrix so for a complete understanding
of the beta oxidation topic make sure to
watch that video if you found this video
helpful make sure the support met
simplified by hitting the subscribe
button below and also make sure to like
this video thank you so much for
watching this video